for the fifth year I think its fifth
year in a row it's up that on the card
there are no cards
for the fifth year in a row we are
taking our show to San Diego for
comic-con
we'll be doing nice we'll be airing a
week of shows live from the historic
Spreckels theater we got lots of
incredible stuff planned incredible
guests lined up including the cast of
the upcoming movie it chapter two the
cast of Veronica Mars is also going to
be joining us plus we have we have a few
surprise guests and you don't want to
miss them so it's all happening is
little unusual not our usual schedule
it's all happening Wednesday July 17th
through Saturday July 20th and I hope we
see you all there yes sir you you have a
question yeah I just wanted you to know
I'm not gonna be there okay
thanks for telling me that I'm sorry to
hear that the lines the traffic the ID
badges it's all a major hassle okay well
you can watch the episodes from
comic-con on TV don't have a TV why not
they're too heavy and also I don't want
wet girls with black hair crawling out
of it okay that only happens in horror
movies yeah
well it's a chance I don't want to take
all right then you can watch on your
computer don't have a computer don't
want the government stealing my ideas
okay fine you can watch on your cell
phone don't have a cell phone radiation
and I used to but dial nine-one-one 11
okay well I guess there's one more thing
you could do what's that sir yeah you
can go yourself
[Applause]
you